The joe rogan experience.
All right.
We're live ladies and gentlemen with a whole new set up a yeah.
Yeah.
When they listen ma'am,
I'm very irresponsible.
You're not going to be really cool is when we get something right back here.
That's the next step.
We're trying to figure out what to put right back there.
Most likely is going to be a green screen cause I'm looking at this right now.
I'm like how dope would it be if we were in fucking space right now?
Yeah.
[inaudible]
so Adderall give you clarity.
That's hilarious.
Cause my kids are trying to get me off it.
Why you're trying to get math.
My fucking kids like that.
I put through Rehab,
give me shit about my fucking hair all tell me it's like no,
it's not like I've never done math except for,
you know,
two times guys married to Tom Arnold.
But aside from that,
you know I've never,
I would never get into math.
It would be very strange if one day it was proven that we are really living in
some sort of self created reality.
It would be like a really traumatizing for a lot of people that have fucked it
up.
You'd be like,
this is what I made.
But it's like,
remember when you were in school and like there was a project and you had to use
your hand and make a Turkey and you put your hand down.
He drew around and then you know,
everybody did their own little Turkey painted it and then the teacher would put
him up in the,
and I'll look at them and some people's,
Turkey's looked like dog shit.
I looked,
I didn't know what the fuck a Turkey looked like.
They didn't even know how to draw around their hand.
Like everything was a disaster.
And other people that beautiful darkies well your life is a work of art.
Your,
your life is like a hand Turkey that you make in grade school.
It's,
you could do whatever you want with that thing.
You can make it super dope.
Yeah.
You know you can,
you can make it so it looks really cool if you put the effort and time into it.
If you really focus on it.
John Travolta met a single handedly,
made more men gay just from this music and from singing and dancing and getting
people to dance.
He probably personally,
it was probably his total overall goal,
which is to say nothing of his bath house work.
Do you mask your farts when you should shit in a public restroom?
No.
Let it out.
You gotta do what you were going to hold up to the left girl.
An idiot.
Jesus Christ.
You have it on your phone.
I love girl farts.
Yeah.
40 year old man.
He's got it on his phone.
Jesus Christ.
Oh yeah.
Anybody who says it doesn't go in your asshole shut it.
He's clearly looking at that and just being like,
yeah,
you fucking,
it's well,
you know it doesn't always go in.
Sometimes it just hits the taint.
Sometimes it's just the that would hurt.
That would hurt.
You got a good grip on the upper deck and it doesn't actually get in the
asshole.
He's just calling the lit up,
pulling the lit up on the macaroni and cheese container.
Just get the steam out.
Yeah,
just Tupperware in that motherfucker.
But sometimes it goes in the asshole freakiest
thing is you know how to rope off everything at a Times Square when uh,
when the ball is going to drop or whatever.
Yeah.
And there's a certain time you can't go past the barricades.
One night I was there and
the guy said,
well you remember the Church of Scientology?
And I said,
yeah,
and he let me in through the barricade.
Real Story.
Dude,
real story.
He probably just wanted to fuck you
[inaudible] handsome guy.
But that's what they told me.
So like that would probably be like 7% or something like that.
If I was,
I was super,
super lean but not doing compared to these guys with these guys are doing,
I was,
I was working out with these guys are doing is like getting real close to death
while keeping giant muscles.
It's fucking madness.
Like this is the nuttiest fucking sport of all time.
Yeah.
It's performance art.
This duck,
I will rip your Dick [inaudible] ass doors.
Those bank fault ass doors of his shit looks like charge our bags.
My grandmother like Moans,
like she's,
she's hurt so bad.
She can't move.
She had an aneurysm 12 years ago,
so she's just lying in bed like that.
Hello.
Here is a man.
She was in just paying the one time.
She does.
She's done from the aneurism on.
They gave her 72 hours to live.
She lived for 12 years.
Yeah,
and it wasn't a good 12 years.
It wasn't a good 12 years,
but see,
your grandfather was getting zero action.
I'd probably do whatever you want it.
This is exactly what I was saying earlier.
GRANDPA's coming in.
You can hide the fucking canola eas,
but you're not high net fucking bloom.
Hey,
she's going to be hairy guy.
That fucking God goes,
oh,
she got a big fucking juicy guy who she's saying at the end of it,
that's when you know you're done.
When you hit the Gaga.
Good.
On this broad,
what I fucking do,
you should say of her,
my brother,
I don't know if she's moaning because of the aneurism.
Gogo Kellogg
from Kellogg cereal.
Right.
He had a thing.
He was very,
you ever see that?
People who masturbate you gotta thing about that.
I mean the whole thing with the corn flakes,
the reason corn flakes were invented was to stop boys from masturbation.
How was it?
How was the idea behind that?
We do that explained this to us before then.
The idea is that spicy foods excite the sensibilities and so if you eat
something that tastes interesting,
you're going to want to come.
So they,
they embed and also Graham crackers.
Graham was another,
these big ante masturbation evangelizers so invent these really
intentionally bland foods.
They like to keep the teenage boys from jerking off so that when they finger,
they're assholes.
They immediately calm.
Exactly
veal.
Keep them in the dark.
Oh yeah,
cow could milk itself.
That would be bad.
And she goes,
Oh,
I'm not the problem with money anymore.
Your father's the one who spends all the money now.
And then she pointed my,
Dan goes,
tell him,
tell him what you spend your money on.
And I've already clicked what this won't be.
And I've gone,
oh wait,
look,
I want to know.
I don't want to know.
And then it goes,
your father gets prostitutes
and I've gone,
oh,
just shut up.
Both of your police and she's gone yet every Wednesday your father,
before he goes to play lawn bowls goes off and gets himself a prostitute.
And then my dad went,
not every Wednesday.
Do you have a catch phrase when you hunt,
when you hit one?
I need one.
Well,
yes.
Blam Blam we eating ham.
I'm not sure if he's going to answer.
Yeah,
you're on the radio.
You're live on the podcast.
Fucking doors over there.
That's all I love.
Say I love you.
I love you man.
We love you too,
man.
No,
that's how you impregnate.
The Sun would come
up a black hole.
We don't know what to do about a black hole.
We can get an infinite amount of Dunkin's to come in it.
Well,
it's,
you know,
mass broken down to the smallest,
right?
It's not going to stop an infinite amount of come.
Trust me,
there's a whole other universe inside.
They're still not big enough for infinite amounts of calm.
Sorry.
The black hole is like,
what the fuck?
So
this is one of the things,
especially talking to college students that I love bringing up,
which is that,
and I'm the first to a minute,
like I have no fucking clue what I'm doing.
99% of the time,
especially when I got started,
I still don't know.
And I've,
I've come to realize like,
and I've got,
I've got,
I've been lucky enough to meet some pretty like successful,
impressive people.
But like you dig under the surface,
we're all just hacking it.
Like we're all just expertise,
experience,
those things all help.
But like every one of us is a fallible human,
all the and rules and status quo we know were created by other fallible humans.
Yeah.
And there's no reason not to look at that and go,
Huh,
does it have to be that way?
Or why is it that way?
And if the reason why is,
well that's the way it is.
Well that's a terrible reason,
you know?
And,
and when you see the world as being that hackable,
so to speak,
like you start to realize,
all right,
well let's just,
let's actually question stuff.
Tell,
did you see a special roadwork?
I heard it's awesome.
So funny.
But he,
um,
I was sitting at the table with my dissing rounds of venture female comics and
we were like eating dessert.
It was like a really like,
sad moment.
He just walks up.
We're like,
hey Dave.
He's like,
oh,
what are you guys having no boyfriend mode?
Tell him what does that tell a story?
We're all from about keep Kimbo slice.
Kimbo slice on ultimate fighter.
Yeah.
When you were guys were doing that,
they didn't even show this on there.
So this guy,
I'm not going to mention his name on the show.
He lost and you can drink all that alcohol you want in the house.
And there's only,
at the time there's only four of us left,
still fighting and one of the other guys is hammered.
Hammered.
He's lost,
right.
Hammered,
wasted.
All of a sudden this guy gets super racist in the house and there's all bunch of
black guys in the house.
I'm sleeping.
And I thought it was a dream.
Kimbo slice and,
uh,
Marcus Jones and this and this d'amico and this demicco Rogers,
comes in my room.
They go,
Yo,
shop,
get up,
dog.
Get up man.
I'm like,
Huh,
why are there three large black guys run my bed?
Kim Goes,
Yo man,
this dude's down there talking about our people.
We're about to jack him up.
I literally,
I thought I was in the gym.
I go,
excuse me,
it's talking about our people dog.
Let's go eff this dude up and like,
listen,
uh,
you guys realize I said,
I'm,
I'm told I'm not down with the race thing.
I'm totally down to fuck this dude up.
But you realize I'm not black,
right.
Kim Goes,
you ain't
no bad.
He goes,
damn,
that's crazy.
Turn around and leave.
And I hear that's why a lot shop,
you can't tell what the hell he is.
I go eight Kimbo that's racist dog,
Ypo.
Just cause I'm athletic and can file you gotta be black.
He goes,
you could be and cute
I guess.
But here's the other thing.
I mean,
I,
I don't even know if the word is trick and I'll,
I mean I totally fell for him.
The shit out of you.
I feel like,
I guess it is trek,
but it's also once he was like,
why would I question that in my life?
No one's ever lied about where they went to school that I knew of.
Right.
These are not lies that in society we're told to look out for.
It'd be one like everyone's like,
does he have another family?
I wouldn't even think about like your school.
Like who cares?
It's like lying about your blood type.
Disruption in a competitive market is actually very,
very enticing to the,
to the second and third tier players because they don't have an advantage.
There are too small to compete against the big guys.
But if they see this disruptive technology,
I think,
well maybe if I hit your ride on that I'm going to overtake everybody.
Um,
and you know,
I can be the blockbuster or it can be the Netflix.
I can be the tower records
or I can be the iTunes.
And we've seen this happen in technology racist before of course,
but I meant like when you're not doing this and you said five hours,
five hours maybe.
Is that because you all juiced up with nicotine all the time?
I think cause I'm old and my prostate tells me it's time to get up.
I take a leak five hours and you're good.
Um,
if I'm lucky,
you know,
get some palm palm juice.
Have you tried some of those pills that help?
What is this doctor Oz who gives a shit?
It's like we were just watching heavy metal and there's like a,
a Caribou carcass here.
It's like,
have you ever thought of like who gives a shit?
It's part of getting old guys get used to it.
Get used to it.
Let's say that
they somehow cooptive and we sell that.
Right?
Tony also replace Alex Jones.
He's waiting.
He's in Austin,
Texas.
You say you're the number one,
but I've got the statistics.
I've got the documents right here and show you're a liar.
Jank you're a new world order puppet.
He seems like he's out there working for the people.
He's not working for the people who went for MSNBC.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you don't get to Msnbc unless you sell your soul to David Ike's.
Reptilians I you see I use a prop on my first open mic and uh,
I didn't realize it was racist.
I'm just race.
What was it?
A black like join the cross burning.
I mean as a monkey with a fucking jockey outfit on and a basketball,
his hat on backwards with a boombox and his shoulder.
I had no idea
it was a punching.
None.
Picking cotton in blackface chained to a plantation stare.
It was open Mike Nights.
Sorry.
Is robbing a white man.
Hey Batman book,
Fat Albert's friend with the hat over his face open.
Dabu Hey,
no dues.
Racist.
I'm sorry.
What were you saying?
I've had sex.
Why life sold after the woman left because he thought I was rational.
You thought it was rational?
No,
cause I remember she was like scratching this area of her body.
When she left.
I was like freaked out so hard.
But I went into my bathroom,
I started Lysol hauling my legs like shape and then dish soap.
And then Lysaght and the next day I,
speaking of 12 step meetings,
I went to my first and only sex addicts anonymous meeting.
I was just like,
something's got to change.
To look at your face was awesome,
but you know,
there's no,
there's very little,
well,
the way for you to convince yourself that you're just like a young man swinging
around,
having a good time,
engaging in the regular sexuality of all human beings when you're spraying Lysol
on here.
And so now,
you know,
it's still use faggot in the column.
I'm not one of those uh,
gay rights activists who,
you know,
when David Spade or Jonah Hill or Alec Baldwin uses Faggot like falls down and
screams and yells and calls for their heads.
I've actually,
you know,
I defended David well a million years ago from glad when they were after him.
I think Louis C K does it a hilarious things with faggot.
So I don't think that it's not a hate word anymore if you can't let straight
people use it when the case,
when the,
their intent is clearly not hateful.
And so I feel like it shouldn't be a problem for people to use the t word tranny
in a non hateful context.
But so many trans people are so invested right now politically in uh,
in stopping its usage at all ever.
And uh,
you know,
in deference to their delicate sensibilities
stopped Ari Shaffir has so many stories about China.
We talked about so many other things besides his stories about China,
which is how we have to keep going.
So you have bout to tell some crazy noodle story.
So they had these noodles is treat noodles you can get,
I was advised the first day,
like you don't want those and show them this video.
What they would do is they would go to the sewer,
they would take raw sewage out of the sewer and then boil it down the way they'd
make wax hash wax,
they'd boil off the sewage and whatever was left that's cooking oil that they
would use.
It's super fucking harmful.
And then sell to like a lot of the street noodle guys.
Yeah.
That face is what I made that same face.
They were cooking with sewer oil,
Bro,
I think we've been parasitized by an astonishing farm of political correctness.
I mean what does Pressa ties lighten there like a parasite that,
oh right.
So in the same way that I like that word that viruses can enter your body virus,
viruses of the Mike and also take over your,
I mean religion is an example of a Mima plex form of some people would be upset
by what I'm saying,
but a form of parasite that kind of rewires your thinking.
And so political correctness is a,
an astonishing form of parasitic thinking where everything is viewed through the
lens of I should not offend anyone.
And so common sense and just reason goes out the window in the pursuit of non
offense.
This is not a subject I'm really into,
but there is a woman,
this German woman who does shit porn where people shit on her and she's like the
queen of Shit Porn.
Don't ask me how I know that somebody posted it on my message board and I
followed a fucking all over link hole.
I went from link to link to link to,
I got to her site and watch some of her videos.
Your side.
Good egg.com.
Uh,
I feel like,
um,
if you tell me in the past what's the core age,
what's the opposite of courage?
I want to say cowardness because either you tough enough to challenge and to
fight or to or in their new car and then you chicken out.
So that's in the past was like the,
the,
the opposite of,
of,
of courage is very high to measure this in those days.
And I believe the opposite of college should they,
is conformity.
You know,
his people get conformed.
Oh,
I,
I don't like my wife the way I used to like,
but I'm never going to divorce because I'm afraid to lose my house or the
situation is so established so I'm going to keep,
so I don't like this job but I got to keep here because better than he is.
So [inaudible] not the hands of the few.
If you get caught on that kind of compromise to,
to maintain because you were you afraid to risk,
that's keep you like one step behind from you,
follow your heart,
follow your ambition.
So that's kind of pretty much where keep you from be at your best because if you
willing to sacrifice,
if you're willing to,
to broke new new challenges.
If you really chew you in the stage of liveliness and,
and excitement and unpredictability,
who make you feel like you're in heaven
even though her neck will fuck though she was determined to do nominate people
shit like go across and
like go across the track too fast.
Right.
And once I see she had a 64 Chevy,
they used to bounce and she loved like old music.
So we're not just bouncing,
listen to BB king and she gonna beat the train.
That bitch hit that first tracking and net went back.
She's like come and muscles to slap the shit out of her knee and then went
through the stern way.
Oh we know I had to jump out to sea in Hola Nica washy drive across the track.
So you pull out your pitches,
hit me too hard.
Muscles like miss the train was coming.
Oh my God,
you bitches.
Sorry.
What's weird when anybody PR like when a guy is like working in an angle and
trying really hard to like position himself as better than he positioned himself
as being like different than every other guy.
Right.
I'm,
you know,
there's a lot of guys out there to doing really negative things.
Like I read this one guy's fucking Twitter page of the day.
It was amazing.
It was just like,
he's,
he might be the ultimate White Knight.
I don't want to give out his Twitter page.
Yeah.
But he,
he might be like the greatest I if I met him,
he probably has almost no blood in his veins is blood sugar is probably zero.
He'd probably faints all day long.
It was so weak.
But one of the things he said is he said,
all,
he said,
although I still practice feminists,
I still practice feminism.
I no longer,
um,
associate I no longer,
well,
what'd he say?
Advertise myself as a feminist because I feel like it's up to women to decide
whether or not I'm doing feminism correctly.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
So I'll still practice feminism,
but I will no longer advertise myself as a feminist.
Jesus Christ.
That's a,
I actually don't even know what to say about that.
Male feminism is a very strange thing,
but we would sit up there all night.
It would be me,
Norton,
mainly Keith and Patrice.
Just Smith.
Billie birther,
fucking Billy comes into the seller,
right?
And she says,
I'm going to the world series.
It's when the mets were playing the in the world share.
He's a subway.
He goes,
I'm going to the game.
We go,
how the fuck?
How do you get tickets?
He goes,
wow,
these dudes hired me to do a show under a bus on the way and are given and right
when he said that,
everybody's eyes lit up.
We're fucking
we.
We did shit like this.
You guys are a good crowd.
And off the bus we beat him to sweat was pouring down Billy's head.
He didn't do it.
He gave the Gig away.
He didn't do it again because we beat them down so hard.
It just fucking animals.
I tell him,
my daughter,
a couple of,
I made me two months ago about a,
there's an old Spanish proverb that says,
Whoa,
um,
habits begin is cobwebs and end up as chains.
Way Easier to break in the beginning than later off.
Right.
Way To put it.
It's a great way to put it.
Wow.
And uh,
anyway,
she just,
she just brought this up,
uh,
you know,
um,
that we were talking about someone she knew and,
and something that she didn't like that they did and she said,
yeah,
but they're still pretty much in the cob web phase,
so they can probably still change it at him.
Was like,
well,
I even,
I didn't remember.
She's like,
Oh yeah,
the cob webs and change things.
Like she really sunk in her and she's like,
yeah,
five societaly.
We're so resistant to looking at mental illness the same way we look at physical
illness.
We're so,
it's so easy.
Paul Gil Martin just made this point when he was on my podcast last week.
If you went up to somebody with diabetes type one diabetes and you were like,
what the fuck dude?
Why don't you just think more positively so that your pancreas makes insulin?
Like what's wrong with you?
Why can't you just make more insulin?
It's like they'd be like,
what are you talking about?
It's the same thing with depression.
People put the onus on you like they,
they look at it like it's a disease of will,
but it's not.
It's a,
it's a biological illness and that's just very hard for people to understand and
so what you end up doing is carrying around a lot of guilt and shame and a lot
of feelings like,
I'm not good enough.
I can't will myself out of this if I just think more positively.
It's not about that,
and I did that for years,
years.
You just deal with it and I destroyed.
Oh,
so many relationships.
The feeling of being a self,
the feeling that we call I,
the feeling of being an ego in the head is what it feels like to be thinking
without knowing that you're thinking.
It's the,
it's the feeling of this next thought,
capturing consciousness.
So when you say that thoughts,
you are identical to thoughts.
So if you're thinking something really fucked up like a,
I'm fat,
I'm a loser,
I'm always going to be a loser.
Like that is identical to who you are because you are sort of framing yourself
in this thought,
these thoughts that you're carrying around your mind there,
what's occupying your consciousness and the,
if those thoughts are on the forefront of your consciousness that they identify
you,
you are,
that you are those thoughts and you are identical to that idea.
Yeah.
And their and their driving behavior and they're driving emotion and they're
driving each subsequent train of thought.
So it's,
it's,
it's determining the,
the,
the future expressions of your consciousness and your body as well.
Those guys,
I mean it's not easy if for example,
Brock was furious when Vince told him that he wanted him to beat the undertaker
that day.
Like in real life like Betty was.
And you were there to see it.
No,
but I talked to somebody who was,
but he was honest with you.
It's not like they lie all day.
Every day.
Tony is going to talk to some people.
Let me tell you a little,
I'll tell you what.
Brock was actually mad.
He was really mad.
He read the script and you just like bullshit.
I'm not picking up.
Fuck you.
Don't undertake undertaker.
Some of the guys that work,
unlike the technical side for the UFC work for the WWE,
ARD,
Brock was crying.
That's what I heard.
That's went to the hospital with the undertaker.
Cried so hard.
He dehydrated himself for that match.
They had to give him an IV
to replenish his teasing thought he killed the undertaker from that concussion
was bad.
Bad.
It was real.
The concussions are real.
You can't,
I don't even buy it was a real concussion.
I probably faked a concussion.
Then dot.
Jt,
I'm not take her to the hospital.
He's got up Bobo and even on the real booboo.
Folks,
if you don't take,
it's a real boob.
La,
show you the fucking band aid on it
for your own belief.
Pitching something at four year olds,
so booboo,
it is a booboo and needs up their day.
Honey,
there's no,
he's not even bleeding.
You don't need a bandaid bandaid.
Okay,
well bandaid make you feel better.
We'll get you a bandaid.
Did took the undertaker and put a bandaid on him.
Tony Hinchcliffe in a gold suit holding the script.
I can't believe it's our real poop.
He's jumping up and down in circles and Vince Mcmahon is standing there shaking
his head.
Got Color of purple.
I'll fucking pent up with rage.
That's how I wrote it
out.
It's a booboo.
Look at the bandaid.
It's real.
It's a real bandaid.
Ladies and gentlemen,
if you doubt it.
What else do you like?
That sucks.
Um,
I was driving,
I live on the east side and I was driving,
I was riding on a TV show for a little while and I was driving to work one
morning and I couldn't get to work because there was so much traffic and I was
just like,
what the fuck is going on?
It's,
it's 9:45 AM on Hollywood boulevard.
Why is the show backed up?
And then I saw people like walking around with these shirts on that said our
wounds are still open
and I feel like a real,
I know I'm an asshole before say this.
I thought it was some kind of record
released
and I was getting so mad.
I thought like a rapper,
like a release day is going on.
It was still open.
Our mouth,
I'll close is moving.
I rustled my toes
pretty,
my teeth is gold.
You're trying to buy my album,
but the shit's already sold out on free style 2014 we won much love.
I've been trying to understand this American phenomena is southern Baptists and
one of the things that I think is the key to this is that I think when they talk
about being born again,
originally baptism was just that.
I mean no,
you can get this through DMT in five minutes,
but at the time of John The baptist,
you get it in five minutes through being droned.
People were lining up on the bank of the Jordan.
They go in,
he holds them under.
If he held him under just long enough,
you could actually induce and near death experience.
New Life Review at the drowning man sees his life pass before him,
hold them out of just long enough and they'd have a near death experience almost
guaranteed.
I mean occasionally they might,
he might've done it too long,
but that was before litigation that you might've lost four litigate.
Yeah.
Good theory actually.
And then you see they come back and they said,
I've died.
I've seen the light.
I'd been born again.
I'm no longer afraid of death.
My life has been transformed in five minutes.
And the baptists were the people who revived baptism by total immersion in the
16th century and probably know in,
in America,
we don't hold the amount of that long cause this is post litigation now.
But you know when,
when the Baptist first got going,
this idea of holding people aren't as long enough.
All their language is the language that relates to near death experiences.
And I don't think that to start with baptism by total immersion was just
symbolic.
I think it was drowning.
Exactly.
It's a beautiful sensual ally.
And I've had to deny myself that central ally for the last three years because I
abused it because we want to spark up a joint right now.
I
want to dive in right now.
Of course,
the Gel,
you're like,
you're like the serpent in the garden of Eden.
Sure.
You want yes.
You sure?
Why not?
I don't want to force you into anything.
You're not,
you're not forcing me.
An interesting mix went na na,
na,
na that.
I'm going to go,
I'm going to go live on Joe Rogan.
Is that bad?
No,
that's not bad.
That's the way to do it.
If you want to dive in,
we'll go.
A little baby hit.
So what I was getting into was,
um,
this,
this teller here,
American shit too.
That's
not that crappy.
Get in England.
That's made by American scientists and botanists.
They all drive muscle cars and they do steroids.
That's so familiar.
That's such a nice feeling.
But do they allow like porn sites like in dorms?
Can kids get download porn?
Well,
I mean there's,
I mean,
Jamie sent me up to go to a site no more.
Well,
yeah,
I mean you don't,
but you could always just download it right from like a torrent.
Well you could just Google porn and it'll be right there.
Right?
That's true.
Yeah.
But I'm just wondering
Monday giving out tips,
guys,
what's your favorite
one?
The one behind,
you know
it's right there.
It is.
Right.
We'll know what to do it again to start all over again with Noah.
Sam,
same deal.
And he also had all of those animals to fuck to no one.
We probably couldn't fuck the animals cause he's had a fuck his kids and make
sure it made more kids.
Am I going to make people get saved?
Those loads.
He was 500 years old.
I really felt that that should have been the Russell Crowe movie.
Yes.
And just him fucking his kids.
You know what I mean?
Just two hours of Russell Crowe fucking his daughter while the fucking rock
monster's guard over them.
Yeah.
I liked the Hollywood executive with this guy.
Like make me one of them kid fucking movies.
Get a Bible
lesson.
If they have a better explanation,
let them write the script.
Hire a couple of Jews,
maybe a kid fucking moving
the idea of speaking about anything,
anything and everything.
Uh,
I think it's detrimental to not be able to talk and to have people that want to
shut other people up based on their ideology or,
um,
anything that they're saying.
If you want to take someone off the air of shut them up,
uh,
or,
or fire them from their job,
I think that's copping out and saying,
look,
I,
I can't logically argue or,
or intelligently argue.
So I just want them quiet.
I want them silence.
Don't they know that by hamstring you,
they fuck up their product and they open up the door to the Internet.
Yeah.
Like the Internet.
It's right there.
It's the wolf at the door.
Oh,
it's right there.
Right there.
And really,
you know,
I was born deaf on one side without a right or,
and,
uh,
in a family that wasn't very supportive.
And,
um,
I thought that success was going to be the key to contentment and happiness.
And like a lot of other people thankfully became successful only to find out
that didn't change anything.
And then the struggle becomes,
okay,
what's it gonna take to be happy?
The most I ever offered a sex worker was,
um,
10 grand.
She wasn't,
this is a,
this is some vampire shit.
This is like when someone's not a sex worker.
Yeah.
It's like,
hey,
like,
not in the Asian guys don't want to fuck you at all.
Like I have no desire to fuck you and you're really,
you're
a Douche bag your crude.
And I go,
okay.
So since,
since I'm not denying any of that,
um,
so this is real money.
Like this isn't a joke.
Like,
you know,
I'm going to,
I'm going to turn you into a horror.
I'm sorry,
I'm going to turn,
you know,
sex worker.
Did you say that to her?
So she's doesn't believe me.
And then I take a picture,
I go,
I'm holding 10 grand right now.
And she goes,
fuck you.
You piece of shit.
Like you think you think like you can buy me.
I go,
all right,
fine.
Whatever.
I don't think much about it.
She calls me two months later.
The text is,
is the offer still good?
I don't even,
I don't even know who the
girl is.
I go,
who is this and what?
What are you talking about?
She calls me and she goes,
you offered me tenure,
and I go,
no,
it's five grand now.
And she goes,
you piece?
I go,
I offered you 10 grand when I was horniest.
Then I was like,
I was playing a game and I wanted it that bad.
I'm like,
when you said no,
it's five grand.
What'd she say that she said,
go fuck yourself.
Then she didn't have no,
then she called me back and then she came and she fucked me and then she didn't
take the money and she left and I thought she forgot.
I said,
hey,
you didn't take the money and still on the thing.
She said,
go fuck yourself.
And then we have a weird,
and we still fuck now we have a weird relationship.
The record at its core is about love.
You know,
being like this one universal truth.
You get a lot of people look to religion.
A lot of people look to drugs and I'm not saying you can't get really spiritual
experiences from all of those things,
but I think love at the end of the day is the one thing that really I've ever
found forced me to want to wake up and really try to be a better human being
every day.
You know?
So that was the main point of the album and the turtles thing was just kind of,
it's a way of saying if you get into an argument with somebody and you realize
it's just pointless and you're going back and forth,
it's turtles all the way down because like nobody really knows shit,
you know?
And we're all just trying to not kill each other.
So I don't know,
I decided it would make a good country song.
Didn't you have like plans on being some sort of a marine biologist or something
at some point?
Yeah,
I tell people that story because this is funny.
On Twitter.
I found this rock,
my daughter found this rock on the beach in Santa Barbara and how all these
holes in it and we're trying to figure out what the fuck it was was an asteroid
or something.
I put on Twitter.
I go,
what's this rock Joe fucking Perry is the first guy to answer me on Twitter and
tells me it's a see stone.
Like these animals had to like burrowed into this stone and create a little
homes really well.
Um,
well anyway,
uh,
oh,
here's a great story.
They landed a fucking comment.
They landed on a comet and uh,
the guy who landed on the comet was wearing a shirt that had all these photos.
Are these drawings of women on it?
Yeah.
Look at this.
I don't care if you landed.
It's
fucking beautiful.
I should hire like a real shower.
Expensive
tailor to make me an awesome suit of that.
Yeah.
The jacket and the pants with a vast,
it ties the whole thing.
Oh,
that would be awesome.
They have the inside of the vest,
like the ones that UFC made me,
they have like little skull and crossbones and the sat and we could have it all
little dicks,
little ticks and some,
and even there was a recent report on Hitler.
Hitler himself was on uh,
a litany of medication and one of them was math.
They were giving a math.
They would give,
do people back down,
fault him for that dude.
The amount of energy that that guy put out during his speeches,
he needed something to level off.
Forget about,
forget about the screaming and yelling.
Just sitting that still
waiting for the right moment.
Building them into that,
that frenzy.
Do you ever watch that Michael Jackson documentary right before he died,
when he drove,
just freeze after he did a dance move.
Let it simmer,
let it simmer.
That's Hitler ship sitting in that fucking chair.
Just getting them crazy.
Just wanting to hear or see the next thing.
What's he going to do?
It's timing.
Is it fucking timing the balls to do that on stage?
The Michael Jackson Hitler simmer moment.
You would have to.
We got to do that tonight at the comedy still.
Alright.
We go.
Okay.
We've got to have this.
You've got to have a dude.
If we had some of the technology,
I could be in your ear telling me you had to keep a straight face after a
punchline.
As you're looking down at some fucked up pose,
I'm just going to let it simmer.
Let it simmer,
let it simmer and release.
So my dad was great.
Yeah,
I had a bird,
had bird feeders out I bought recently and they found out about it and now they
won't leave my house alone.
They're there like every day.
You amazing.
That's cool dude.
That's pretty dope.
Yeah.
They're loud too loud that they're annoying as fuck.
No,
you didn't hear flows on put that will let them into your spiritual compass.
How is it that it's illegal if you don't clean up after your dog,
but you're allowed to just have your fucking horse shit everywhere.
Empty.
It's giant asshole.
1200 pound body of stewed grasses.
I'm sorry.
Is this cobblestone?
This is a dirt road.
You farmer.
Fuck.
Pick up after that donkey.
Your donkey.
Just Shit.
All of my Prius
dog,
he's not that green.
This is contributing to global warming.
Donkey was dirty ass.
All Brian said he didn't like Paris in his name.
He's in bed with the chicken
mark.
Like I never said anybody.
I only done this before.
Oh my God.
Of course.
I always work on
bringing the fucking parents into the courthouse.
We would now like to call a prosecution witness.
The Burbank Paris.
I've never seen this before.
No.
Roofie what are you talking about are,
you
know,
two heads is fine.
I take two hits all the time and I drive an ingrown hair.
You know,
all you need to do is you need to do shit with that stuff.
Kills everything.
It'll tell ah,
Eddie and that worked out at 24 hour fitness and there's this dude who was the
manager there.
It was a cool guy.
We just talked to them and uh,
they had sent him over from the Santa Monica Place.
He was like a real personable,
real friendly guy.
Like he,
you know,
real easy to like.
And so,
uh,
the Santa Monica police brought him in because they needed to get that place
cleaned out because he had basically become just a fuck house.
Yeah,
the close the shower hose them down.
Everyone that'd be common condos.
But my buddy ended up working,
that's how I found out I,
but I ended up working at the same place and they used to have to trap nudes,
gay dudes that were fucking in the sauna and stuff.
And
I told the cop came cause it was right next to a police station.
How people die,
Bro.
Don't trap me in the Sauna.
Make me fuck.
I will do it.
Are you ready?
You Ready?
You better let me out of here,
man.